hey youtubers it's Charlie so exciting
news DC brew birth number one just
dropped Geoff Johns is effectively
fixing the DC Universe so I'm gonna
explain what's going on with flash
superman/batman rebirth pretty much
every character in the Justice League is
getting a rebirth title each of the
other Justice League
rebirth characters will happen pretty
soon flash rebirth number one Superman
rebirth number one Batman rebirth number
one they'll all drop in the next couple
of weeks but effectively think of it as
a retuning of all the characters the
thing I really like about this is that
it puts the flash at the center of the
DC Universe again in the same way he was
at the center of the universe during
flashpoint which I know kind of gets
into flash TV show stuff it's all so
much fun how this weaves together even
though technically the comics are
slightly different from the TV shows so
what the hell is going on everybody's
freaking out because DC changed a bunch
of its continuity rebirth isn't as
complicated as it sounds if you haven't
been reading comics a whole bunch don't
worry you don't have to go back and read
a bunch of old comics but you can if you
really want to but what happened in the
last ten years is that DC editorial
decided that is a way to help new
readers get excited about comics they
wanted to make it really simple so they
just said okay
all of this continuity pre flashpoint
does not exist anymore and that was like
editorial hitting a hard reset button on
the back stories of all of its
characters so any of the adventures that
you read from the 80s or the 60s or the
90s or even the early 2000s as of the
beginning of the new 52 technically none
of those things happen even inside DC
editorial it was a very controversial
decision because your bet you're
basically saying that like all of these
comics thousands and thousands of
stories and characters their lives did
not matter before the new 52 on a
creative level what it seemed like the
new 52 was doing was doing a darker take
on the characters just making it darker
grittier within a couple weeks a giant
portion of longtime comic book fans gave
it a hard pass just said these are not
the characters that I love I'm not
reading this anymore and a lot of that
was reflected in like the business
financial side of things like it just
they just did terribly on a financial
level so DC did the Andrew Garfield to
Tom Hollands spider-man thing where you
do a quick refresh in a very short
amount of time and say okay let's fix
this
John's kind of rides in with his Green
Lantern ring in his Superman cape and
fixes everything by doing the same thing
for all of DC's characters that he had
done with the flash previously like
bringing back Barry Allen and flash
rebirth doing the same thing with Green
Lantern so I'm no I'm blowing a lot of
smoke up Geoff Johns but but he's not
the only person that worked on this
there were a lot of other people
involved a lot of creative people a lot
of artists a lot of writers so threw a
big twist in DC rebirth number one Geoff
Johns reintegrates 80 plus years of DC
history into modern continuity so if
you've been reading comics for a long
time and if you remember a crisis on
Infinite Earths during the 80s how it
tuned a bunch of DC continuity they
killed off a bunch of characters and
they combined up couple backstories
rebirth is making it so that all those
things are canon now now that doesn't
mean that you need to go back and read
all 80 plus years of comics rebirth
itself is a great place to start reading
comics it might be a little confusing
but Geoff Johns is a pretty good writer
so he's pretty easy to pick up if you
have no idea who the characters are but
the thing that most people are talking
about online people that have read the
comic if you haven't read it I'm gonna
talk about a few spoilers so just
careful for DC rebirth spoilers there
are a couple of characters involved a
couple of twists in the story so the
thing everyone's talking about is the
return of the classic version of Wally
West the really goofy one with the
yellow costume and the red hair he's
this disembodied voice he's stuck in the
Speed Force and he's trying to come back
he notices that something is wrong with
the universe
someone fundamentally changed something
and everything went to so it's like
saying that the new 52 was a really bad
dream but the bigger twist is finding
out who's responsible for that
and I'll say it careful for spoilers one
more time just in case you haven't read
DC rebirth okay so the big twist is that
it's dr. Manhattan from Watchmen if you
haven't read Watchmen or you haven't
seen the movie at the end of that story
he goes on this really existential
journey about you know like what does it
mean to be human what am i right now so
as he goes off to Mars to be by himself
and think about life humanity the
universe and everything he starts to
experiment with universes to see what
would happen if I were to take hope away
from the DC Universe so what DC read
birth is saying is that dr. Manhattan
sucked all the hope out of the DC
universe just as an experiment to see
what would happen to all the heroes so
the new 52 is effectively hopeless which
i think is just hilarious
so DC rebirth is an attempt to correct
that so it's not a reboot of the
characters it's just a way to say
they're gonna try and fix the mistakes
of dr. Manhattan but I think what we're
all hoping is is they don't turn dr.
Manhattan into the big bad like it isn't
dr. Manhattan versus the DC universe
because he's not an evil character so we
don't really know how the story's gonna
play out this is how it started this is
the reason they decided to do rebirth
but it's a huge event so I recommend you
all check it out it's way more
interesting than what they're doing with
Captain America right now Marvel just
dropped the new Captain America comic it
was also a very big WTF twist that I'm
not gonna spoil right now but people are
going crazy online but what's happening
later tonight is I'm posting my arrow
finale video after that airs be sure to
subscribe to get that video there is
gonna be a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video and because there's so much DC you
know rebored flash for now and stuff
happening I'm gonna go ahead and crown a
giveaway winner from last night I'm just
gonna do extra DC giveaways this week
just because so much awesome stuff is
happening congratulations to the latest
giveaway winners acti be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details that's
just on the about page so I'll remind
everyone about the new round of the
giveaway whenever I post that arrow
video tonight so even if you have been
watching arrow this season I would
recommend you check it out finales and
premieres are always a huge deal and
without giving flash finale spoilers
away because some of you might not have
watched that yet I'm not expecting what
happened in the flash finale to
completely wipe the slate clean for all
the other TV shows but there will be
ripples and consequences felt as a
result of what Barry did so I'll talk
more about that in my arrow video later
tonight so why you guys wait for that
arrow finale video to post tonight you
can click here for my flash finale video
I talked a little bit about what's going
on at season 3 and you can click here
for my flash season 3 Supergirl season 2
promo video they're teasing a big
four-way crossover it's gonna be awesome
so thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight